okay Leute ist das jetzt offiziell ich
darf Rente beantragen mein neuestes
Lieblingsspielzeug ein Puzzle Rasierer
dieses Ding hat mein Leben verändert und
wenn ich euch sage Leben verändert dann
meine ich Leben verändert kennt ihr das
ihr habt euch was schönes Neues zum
Anziehen gekauft doch nach kurzer Zeit
entstehen hässliche Fusseln halt stopp
hier kommt der Fusselrasierer ins Spiel
so sieht die Jacke vorher aus
[Musik]
und so nachher der Unterschied ist
unglaublich
jetzt mal ohne Witz ich habe einfach ein
Greenscreen Mantel
wie viele Sachen ich aufgehört habe zu
tragen weil sie hat eine gewissen Zeit
so komische Fusseln an den Ärmeln oder
an den Achseln hier bekommen haben mit
diesen Dingen
dann ist es einfach wieder wie neu das
ist so geil das Ding guck mal wie viele
Fusseln hier drin sind